Can you address fasting before chemo?
What is the benefit?
I have a friend with breast cancer who does a 500 calorie a day,
die at the day before chemo and chemo day and the day after.
Is this a good approach?
So yes, that is a very good approach.
I talked about that in my blog post on chemo protocol.
So that's what I'd recommend.
You know, everybody do fast, do a 24 hour fast.
The day before you do the chemo, and I think you could just start eating right after the chemo.
So the chemo, the idea of it, if you think of it like a cartoon,
the chemo cancer is very metabolically active.
So like a cartoon, it's very hungry.
So it's like gabbling up things around.
Just devour everything.
But if you like starved the day before the chemo, it's going to be really hungry.
You can think of it that way.
It's going to be super hungry.
And then you pump chemo into your system.
It could gobble up the chemo.
Now, the studies that are out there were done by, I think,
oncologist email oncologist, I heard her speak once and met her at a seminar a few years back.
I think out of the University of Southern California School of Medicine.
And she did this with, she actually had a patient that fastened before chemo and did,
and decreased her symptoms of chemo by about 50%.
So she started doing this with her patients having them fast before chemo.
And she, she saw a 50% decrease in symptoms.
Now, I don't know if you can really measure.
If the chemo work better because your control group, I mean,
everybody's so different with chemo, you can't, you know, really measure it that well.
But there are some studies out there.
You've been Google some studies on fasting before chemo.
So we always suggest it's 24 hour fast before chemo.